hey guys it's justine and today i just
wanted to kind of talk to you guys about
some of the things that have been going
on with apple recently obviously you
know the iphone 13 came out last month
the apple watch just recently got
released and i never even gave you guys
an update on which one i decided to go
with in my review unit i had the green
version and i decided to go with the
starlight so check that out i decided to
do the starlight because this gold phone
is not really that gold so i kind of
wanted them
to match so that's the current setup
that we have going on but this video
today i've actually partnered with rhino
shield so thank you guys so much for
partnering with me on this video i
thought this video was gonna be like a
simple hey check out my cool rhino
shield iphone case it's gonna protect
you from drops and your daily impacts
they have tons of colors they've got all
sorts of customization which yes that is
all very very very true but what i
didn't realize is that they were gonna
send me so many cases to show you guys
just
hold on a second
we might need to zoom out here because i
don't think they're all going to fit
what
are you
guys
do
oh we're not done yet
[Music]
this is amazing where's my phone even at
ernest they also have 3d impact screen
protectors to go with the phone cases
they even have exclusive collections
with the nba nasa league of legends and
pac-man they have a variety of colors of
prints that you can mix and match with
your style and you can also design your
own case with photos names or text and
they even have apple watch and airpods
cases that you can customize to match
your phone they now have these all
available for the iphone 13 and if you
have an android they also have them for
android phones as well they have a
lifetime warranty for all of their cases
they ship worldwide and they have free
shipping on qualified orders they even
have this really nice usb c to lightning
braided cable they seriously have so
many different combinations and i think
the one that i am going to settle on is
this one it's kind of subtle but i like
this a lot because it has the protective
back on it but i can still see the gold
color and obviously this is one of my
favorite colors and the pink also
matches the airpods case they do have a
couple different options for these backs
because this one actually isn't magsafe
compatible so if you do want something
that is magsafe they do have one of the
clear protectors that is much thinner so
you'll still be able to use magsafe i
feel like i definitely need to do one of
the custom cases and put maddie on it
i'll put a link in the description where
you guys can learn more about rhino
shield for the iphone 13 and you can use
my code ijustine13 at checkout for 20
off in the first week and then 10 off
afterwards so like i said the iphone has
been out for almost a month now it's
kind of crazy to think that that month
has actually gone by so quickly so for
the most part ios 15 has probably been
one of my favorite ios releases i did
make a video talking about some of my
favorite features in ios 15. but the one
thing that i love so much is actually
the focus mode i was surprised that i
liked this as much as i did because one
of the things that was so shocking to me
was to be able to pick up my phone and
not see a single notification my phone
is constantly being bombarded with
notifications all day long so to be able
to set a focus mode when i'm sleeping
when i'm working or just when i don't
want to be disturbed has been so cool so
we upgraded my mom to an iphone 13 and
she was getting an upgrade from the
iphone 11 which honestly isn't that huge
of an upgrade but even she noticed how
much better the camera quality is she is
always taking photos of the dogs and our
little niece and it's so funny because
the first thing that she said is like
wow like this ultra wide camera it's so
much more clear and i'm like yeah it is
my dad has the iphone 12 which we did
recently upgrade him to before the
iphone 13 came out and my grandmother we
upgraded her to the iphone 13 pro we
didn't get her the pro max because she
was coming from the iphone
actually so to go from that to the 13
was such a huge upgrade for her so
graham i hope you're enjoying your new
iphone wait oh my god wait a minute pro
res is actually out in the beta i didn't
even show that to you guys so this is my
beta phone and to be able to access the
prores all you have to do is go in and
turn on the prores when it's actually
out there it is apple freaking pro res
so you just turn it on like you turn on
the pro res for the photos it's in the
formats under video i am currently
running the beta so that's why i do have
access to it it's much like shooting
photos here you'll see you can turn the
raw on and off and when you go into the
video it also does the same kind of
feature you just click the pro res here
on
and off so on this phone it says that i
can have a max recording time of 149
minutes i can't believe i actually
forgot about the prores that's gonna
have to be a separate video but i do
plan on really testing that out
especially with the new macbooks that
were announced as many of you have seen
the new m1 pro and m1 x max no m1 mgs
i'm going to be doing this i keep
messing up the names the m1 pro and the
m1 max those are the two new chips with
the two new macbooks we have the 14 inch
macbook and the 16 inch macbook pro and
i'm so excited about this because the m1
chip as they're transitioning away from
the intel chips so really seeing
firsthand over the last year how
powerful the m1 macbook 13 inch was i
honestly cannot even
wrap my mind around how powerful these
new macbook pros are gonna be and again
it sucks because i'm the type of person
that really struggles to enjoy the now
because i'm already thinking ahead i
mean as soon as that m1 macbook came out
i was like oh my gosh i cannot wait for
the next version like what is the 16
inch gonna be like what are these next
chips gonna bring us and now i'm already
thinking like okay if this is what you
have crammed into these macbooks what
are you freaking gonna do when you come
out with a new imac pro or a new mac pro
tower like it's going to be honestly so
mind-blowing that i was sitting there
watching the keynote and i was getting
excited to do work i was getting excited
to edit and i am somebody who actually
really loves to edit so like the filming
process being in front of the camera is
fun like i really like it because it's a
part of the storytelling process but for
me man when you get into that editing
that's where i shine but since it is my
youtube channel and i'm in it i also
have to be in the videos too so it kind
of
it's like hold on a second how do i wear
so many hats so the iphone has been
incredible i'm so excited to test out
prores i'm so excited that i actually
forgot about it because it's not in my
main phone because i do have the beta
running on my secondary device just in
case because i don't like to run betas
on my main phones anymore only because
it is a beta and i'm sure there's
nothing wrong with it but i do just like
to be extra cautious and run it on
something that isn't my main phone so
the apple watch as an update like i said
i ended up going with the starlight and
it actually matches kind of like my new
aesthetic here what do you guys think of
the new desk are you excited about my
new studio i cannot wait i'm actually
working on a full build out so i'm kind
of in this weird temporary transition
because i wanted to film in it but yet
like it's not ready to be seen and we
don't really have it all set up yet but
it's been a pretty exciting process i
mean i actually was there from the very
beginning of building this like i was in
this studio
when the walls weren't even up there
were a bunch of like outlets and stuff
over here i was like you gotta get rid
of the outlets can't be there because i
need to have this beautiful white wall
we can't be messing it up with outlets
anyway that's gonna be coming soon i
know a lot of you guys who have been
watching my videos and following me for
a really long time may remember the old
days of the white wall so in my review
version i had the green apple watch so
the green was a much darker green than i
thought in all of the press materials it
looked like it was a lot lighter and
when i first unboxed that i was like oh
my goodness this is dark but i really
like the color but for me i definitely
wanted to have kind of this lighter look
and the star light is just really nice
like i can't actually figure out what
color this is it seems like it's mostly
silver like i don't think that i would
really say that this is a gold color but
it really does match the back
of the gold iphone 13. normally during
my apple watch reviews i'm super active
but for some reason i don't know what i
did but i hurt my knee and during the
review i was doing a run like my knee
gave out i was like what is happening do
i have arthritis do i need to go get
surgery like what's what is going on
during the pandemic i basically became a
runner and it was so much fun i really
enjoyed running and now i'm i'm
concerned so thank you to everyone on
twitter who gave me some tips to help
rehab this to help reduce inflammation i
was like oh my god do i even need to go
to a doctor no i just need to be on
twitter you also might have seen in my
apple recap video that they came out
with three new colors of the homepod
mini they have this yellow this orange
and like this midnight blue kind of
color now the whole pod mini is honestly
pretty impressive and i loved they were
showing like these demos if you can just
like bring your phone close to it and if
you use the new voice music subscription
so they have like this new tier now for
apple music and i'm calling it the voice
plan so really you just use your voice
and i think this is a great plan for
people who might have a home pod and
they just want to have apple music and
have access to playlists and basically
just tell siri to play music that's
mostly how i use my homepod but of
course if you do want to make your own
curated playlists if you do want to have
the spatial audio and the lossless audio
but since i do have the apple one
subscription and a family plan i already
do have the full apple music bundle in
with that but i really like this as an
option for people who just buy a homepod
and they're like i don't really need all
of those other features i just want to
use my home pod listen to music and use
this as kind of the home kit enabler for
my home home kit enabler that's what
we're going to call it so the thing that
i really am most excited about is
testing out these
get out of here bug i know these lights
are very enticing but this is my place
i am here not you i'm so excited to test
out the new m1 macbook pros i was really
having this debate like do i want to get
the 16 inch or do i want to stick with
the 14 inch because the 13 inch macbook
was just a little bit too small but
having the 14 inch would be slightly
bigger but it would be still smaller
than the 16 inch but man having that
extra screen real estate is gonna be so
nice and then i had the dilemma of do i
want the silver or do i want the space
gray and in the time frame that it took
me to purchase the macbook that i wanted
i did end up going with the completely
specked out space gray with eight
terabytes of storage space oh god i'm so
excited i put both the silver and the
space gray into my cart and i was like
okay which one do we want and then my
sister and i were having this text chat
back and forth trying to figure out
which one we wanted and then we decided
to both go with the space gray i mostly
chose the space gray because the
keyboard now is all like it's fully
black there's no see-through like you
don't see the keys like a 13-inch
macbook now you can actually see through
so there's like a space gray kind of
silver or the aluminum that you can see
whereas this one is just the whole
keyboard is dark so i thought if i want
to have that kind of blend in a little
bit more with the entire case like maybe
i'll just
do the space gray honestly i don't even
know but i took too long to order and
now my order is being pushed to the
beginning of december so it's gonna be a
very merry christmas early gift to
myself at the beginning of december when
i get this thing in anyway just want to
give you guys an update on some of my
thoughts of what's been happening in the
world of apple and me personally i
haven't been posting as much as i
normally do some of you may have noticed
but there's been a lot of stuff going on
over here in this camp like getting a
new studio traveling back and forth to
visit my family and just so many other
little things like i don't really vlog
anymore so i don't really share my
entire life with you guys like i used to
so it's kind of crazy because i feel
like i'm living this like whole secret
life over here because i don't post
everything online anymore and now
freaking dealing with like this knee
injury it's taking away my energy outlet
of being able to work out so i'm just
i'm very sad about it so i'm hoping that
this heals up quickly and i can get back
to doing all of my activities again
thank you guys for all of your healing
tips and all of your well wishes well
thank you guys for watching if you guys
haven't subscribed already please do so
by clicking subscribe hit the bell to be
notified when i post new videos and i
look forward to seeing you guys in some
of my next videos there's lots of fun
coming up it is officially sober the
tech season is here i'll see you guys in
the next one
[Music]